Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us here today for our 139th episode!
139th year of the Hydraulics Wiki today!
But maybe there might be issues again, huh?
BAU BAU!
Hello!
FUWAMO friends may be joining us today for the very first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
We should get the hashtag #button, huh Moco-chan?
Hashtag #button the doggy part!
What is that?
When you press it there's a hashtag.
This is hashtag.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's the middle of the week.
Are you ready to go?
Feeling energized!
Maybe not quite yet.
Maybe still a bit sleepy.
That's okay, Ruffians!
Let's start the day together, ha!
FUWAMOCO-chan, let's start it out on the best paw ever!
I raise you good.
That was some exciting things, right Moco-chan?
Something other than what's about to happen.
Do we take the bandaid off first, Ruffians?
Hai.
You just woke up?
Time to pull the bandaid off!
Pull the band-aid off!
Please do it off.
Rip it off!
I don't want to see the parasite, Moco-chan!
What kind of trouble have you been in recently?
Danger!
BAU BAU
Is this a bad one?
I don't know.
Let's take a look.
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Oh my gosh, what is this?
The most terrifying pumpkin!
Behold, Pero!
I behold and I don't like it.
Don't look at it.
BAU BAU.
I don't know, Ruffians!
If you saw a house with a pumpkin like this in front of it, what would you do?
I don't know.
I think it's best you don't approach it.
Don't approach the house.
Stay far away.
You kicked the pumpkin!
Oh, that's right!
It's right!
It is!
Pat the pumpkin!
You eat the pumpkin!
Eat the pumpkin!
That's kind of nice.
You might have to have some very strong teeth, though.
They might have nasty candy, see?
Right?
I think it's best you don't go.
Yeah, go to a different house, you know?
With maybe a less nasty pumpkin.
Less nasty pumpkin equals more delicious candy, right?
More candy, yeah!
What did you say?
Trick or treat at this house?
Or maybe a big BAU BAU?
Probably a big BAU BAU, right?
Probably, yeah.
That's what I was thinking.
But then you were thinking it too hard.
I was thinking it too, yeah.
Probably a big BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
There's something else that's happening on Halloween very shortly.
Let's take a look at some exciting stuff!
Yes!
Kawaii-senpai has a very exciting 3D live come out on Halloween in Japan!
It's called G-Rub in Jigoku!
J-Rap in Jigoku!
It's more Halloween themed.
Like, Calli-senpai is already pretty spooky, no?
So it's sort of counter-weeping.
Not only is it gonna be J-Rap, but Calli-senpai also has a new 3D model that she's gonna be revealing.
But, also!
Well, FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be there as guests!
It's gonna be on the 31st at 5am PT.
A bit early.
A little bit of an early day, but we hope that you'll be the- look at us there!
Be the coolest dogs ever!
Yeah!
We can guarantee it!
Damnit dog!
Yeah!
Right, Ruffians?
Huh?
We're cool, right?
Extra chilly?
No!
Extra cool!
Can't you see our cool poses?
Huh?
Yeah!
Right!
Cool!
Cool, right?
Cool?
You'll be there, FUWAMOCO!
Extremely cool baby!
Cool, the coolest!
Yes!
If only we had a kite and the hat's kinda like cowling silk by then.
Although it might be uncomfortable for our ears.
Do they make one so the ears can come out?
Is there a hat with the ear holes?
If our ears dig out of them, will we still be cool though?
That's the question.
You would think we would be cooler with hats with the ear holes.
Cute way to cool!
We're cool here, okay?
Use your eyes.
You can see.
Very, very cool.
But we hope that you'll watch and you'll see us there together with Calli-senpai for the first time in 3 days.
Rapping and being the coolest demon dogs.
Start your Halloween off with this.
Please check it out, okay?
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, we also got a special delivery this year.
You might have heard about it.
hololive just released their first TCG!
The hololive Official Card Game!
And the delivery!
It was a bunch of cards!
Yeah!
We got one set for me, one set for Moco-chan!
And they even said, FUWAMOCO, do you want some more?
We're like, oh, yes please!
Yes!
Yeah!
And well, you know what?
We got a small package!
Yes!
And we got a big package!
And we're like, oh, okay, maybe the big package is probably something else.
Probably the small one, you know?
Right!
It was the big one.
It was the big one!
That's huge, Ruffians!
Can you guess how many we received?
How many?
How many booster packs?
We bought 240 booster packs!
240!
That's insane Ruffians!
We can't do that, we can't do that.
How long did it take to open one booster pack?
I don't know, we're not the best at that kind of thing.
I don't have that much experience.
It's huge, right?
We do!
Calli-senpai!
She had a bunch of fun opening the most cheap couple days ago!
And she even got the rare Suisei-senpai card!
Ruffians, would you want something like that from us?
Card opening.
We haven't played the TCG simulator.
No, no, we haven't played that game.
We don't have to play the simulator anymore.
Yeah, we don't have the simulator.
We can open the cards ourselves.
Yeah.
I see only yes, I don't see no.
I saw a shirt.
A shirt.
He's up on it.
He's very polite.
But Ruffians, I don't know, it might take us quite a while to open them with our paws though.
I don't know Moco-chan.
We'll have to see it!
But please check that out too Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Opening battle!
Who can open the booster pack?
Who can open it faster?
Is that what's important?
That's what's important.
BAU BAU!
Who else is more excited?
Halloween's Booking!
Brand new news!
Wow, IRyS-senpai!
She just announced that she'll be having a brand new Booking!
This will come out.
I'm imagining!
I'm gonna cry!
BAU BAU!
We're really excited to hear IRyS-senpai's earring!
We both really really like it.
It has quite an earring vibe to it.
So we hope Ruffians will give it a listen before we get into the Halloween season with it!
It's going to be coming out not too long from now.
In about 12 hours it will be premiering at 8pm PT.
So please go check it out on Aya-senpai's channel.
BABYMETAL's NAKISO.
You have to check it out, okay?
Yeah!
Oh, have we listened to Elizabeth Blackbird?
We did!
It was amazing!
Please check it out too, Carol-P!
Moco-chan was dancing a little bit.
Interpretive dance.
Please check it out!
BAU BAU!
You know, not only is Aya-senpai getting into the halloween spirit, but Shiori!
Shiori-chan has a very smooth... Did you say Shiori-chan?
Shiori-chan.
Cause I love Shiori too.
Cool!
Nerissa-chan!
Biboo-chan!
Shiori-chan!
But she's gonna be having a very spooky 3D Halloween theme coming up.
It starts at 6pm today.
It's not quite Halloween, but everybody's starting it off early because Halloween is awesome!
Extra extra fun!
Shiori is working super hard for this team.
Doing all these kinds of things.
Preparations for months and months.
Yeah, we're sure it's going to be super duper fun!
You know, she's gotten a bunch of help and support from the Novelians.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Ah, Halloween.
Why?
You know, it's just like Halloween, senpai.
It's kind of, you know.
So, what is Miss Halloween gonna do for us?
Lots of Halloween streams this week.
Why?
I wonder why.
I wonder why, huh?
But we're really looking forward to seeing what she is working so hard to create.
Please check it out on camera!
It's 6pm PTM today.
Shiori is always nice.
No.
Correction, Shiori is always cute.
But today, extra spooky.
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited.
I can guarantee one thing though, Shiori-chan.
Shiori-chan, this is very weird.
This is very weird.
Can you stop that?
Shiori's eyes are probably gonna be glowing.
Shiori-chan, all of a sudden you've never said this.
Maybe she's dressing up as Shiori-chan for Halloween, huh?
Who is that?
BAU BAU!
We had something very exciting happen here with us!
On Twitter!
We are super surprised!
Because it looks like the Queer and Pop Team Epic, Boku Musou, sent you us FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
So cute!
We're on it!
Yeah!
What do you think, Ruffians?
So cute!
Yeah, you know, we saw some Ruffians say, you know, what was FUWAMOCO's pop team epic debut?
What?
I don't know about that.
Maybe that would be more like...
Pup team epic?
Pup team epic!
I don't know, Rubin.
I don't think we're silly enough to be able to keep up with that kind of world, you know?
What do you think, Kai?
Maybe?
Maybe not.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
You look super cute here though!
Thank you so much Mocobo-sensei for the super special illustration!
BAU BAU!
That would be a great emote.
It's just great all around, you know.
Yes!
Wonderful!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
Actually, today's FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's a bit chilly.
Yeah.
Although I did get a little bit scared, Ruffians.
Because you know, we got out of an elevator.
And then right in front of us as the doors opened, there was a cute little girl just sitting in front of us.
And I thought, and I thought it's dark water!
You know, we just watched the horror movie Dark Water together in the Doggy Pack.
She was a bit startled.
I was a little scared!
And I was like, what's wrong?
She's like, startled.
Wait, did you startle the little girl?
She goes, no, I was startled by the little girl!
She did not have a red bag, no.
It's okay, I survived, Ruffians.
We went on a nice walk, we got something warm to drink.
And you know while we were walking around, Fuwawa started singing Haru Ichiban, a song by the Counties.
And you know it's kind of a spring song.
I don't know why, but he just kind of came into my head.
It was not spring anymore!
He came into my head and I just felt like, oh...
You don't want to drink falling leaves!
And that's what she's singing.
Spring song.
I don't know.
It's always good for a good song.
It's basically winter.
Yeah.
No.
You know, it can be spring inside your heart whenever, right?
Exactly.
Sing it if you feel like it.
Yeah, you know.
It's against the season, huh?
What song should I have sung, Moco-chan?
How many ball songs are there?
Konayuki ga sawa.
That's winter!
I can only think of one thing.
Is there anything about falling leaves?
Konayuki don't seem to understand.
That's the only thing I need for fall.
Is that a fall song?
I don't know!
Maybe you can't find any fall songs, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Maybe.
But it was really nice, FUWAMOCO!
I hope that you can get out for some really nice autumn walks too.
BAU BAU!
It's a little bit scary.
Are you gonna pick me up?
Yeah.
I need a little bit of a... This is like a puppy up.
I need a pup talk, Moco-chan!
I can't deal with the fact that year is about to end!
Moco-chan!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
One last time!
This here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And that means you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
How are you feeling?
Huh?
Has it been a bit rough recently?
We know it's difficult, you know?
It's getting colder, things are changing.
It can be scary, but sometimes it's very necessary to be able to get a bit of a breather and a change of scenery just to realize how important things are and how they impact your life as well.
We know it can be uncomfy.
It can be sad.
But surely things will change for the better!
But some things also will never change too.
And that thing is that... We'll be here!
We'll always be here!
We'll be here cheering you on, okay?
And... Now we're here to protect your smile!
We know that you can do it!
No matter how many times you stumble.
And we'll show you that we're the same too, okay?
Let's keep on standing up and keep going forward.
Got it?
We're always with you Ruffians!
Let's do our best!
You can do it!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Thank you FUWAMOCO-chan!
You got it!
Understood!
I saw Ruffians be like, yes boss, got it boss.
Good!
You understand!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best, FUWAMOCO!
Right through the end of the year into 2025!
FUWAMOCO!
Let's look at our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Fluffy and Fuzzy!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
We love having guests to FUWAMOCO!
It's just like us too!
Little FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, are you confused?
Moco-chan.
Hai?
This is a competition.
Competition?
But why is FUWAMOCO here?
I don't know, but give me FUWAMOCO and FUWAMOCO!
Why is it a competition?
The answer is obvious!
I guess there's no competition, huh?
We're still puppies, but we're grown-up puppies.
They're super cute though!
They're being cute!
They're puffy and fuzzy.
BAU BAU!
Like that.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Why, you know, we sure that if we'll be a fuzzy or anything like us, that they'll always be the best of friends and get along super well, even though they might fight over food or pizza.
Toys, dolls, beds, toys, yeah.
You name it!
Oh, I sure love these super happy puppies!
They get to go on lots of walks and you know, get to have some intense fun in some deep mud puddles!
Leaf puddles?
Piles?
Yes!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Speaking of leaf piles, huh?
Beautiful!
That's a really nice auto-walk.
Even nicer than my walk, huh?
A lot more leaves, huh?
Ruffians, it looks like you got into some of the leaf piles there.
Is that actually a leaf pile or is it just the ground?
It's just that many leaves.
So many leaves.
I don't think it's a pile, I just think that's how it is.
Right!
I feel like I can smell the leaves.
Can you smell it, Ruffians?
What is it?
Crispy.
Crispy smell.
Dirt.
Can you smell it?
Can you smell the dirt?
I can smell it.
You can smell it.
Yeah.
Crispy a little bit?
Yes.
Leaf carpet.
So nice.
Crunchy.
Hopefully crunchy under your feet and not in your teeth.
Yeah.
Don't eat the leaves.
Love them.
Don't eat them.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Wow, let's take a look at our Question of the Day today!
Our Question of the Day is... Today!
I have a question for FUWAMOCO!
Since the Akibamise has shut down... It hasn't yet.
Soon, very soon.
Is there another go-to Mister Donut location that you would suggest Ruffians should head to for condomings if they visit Tokyo?
Like Moco-chan said, you know Akihabara store is still gonna be open for a few more hours here today.
It's closed right now.
In a few hours, it'll be open again for the last time.
But, you know, it's hard because, you know, it can't really replace FUWAMOCO.
It can't be replaced.
But, you know, for FUWAMOCO reasons, let the Ruffians go and have yummy pomeranians and a nice break at all locations.
You know, whichever is most cozy, most convenient.
But,
If we had to recommend just a location, you know, there's another very special Mitsu-do right outside of the Nakano Broadway.
You know, they have a lot of anime stars.
So you know, Akiba's nice, Nakano Broadway nice, and there is a
You know they also have the donut buffet there, so you can sign up for that if you want to!
You can't just be like, I want the buffet now.
No, you can't.
You have to prepare your hunger in advance.
But you know that's where we went together with Advent!
It was super fun!
We have good memories there too.
You know, when we were there together with Advent!
Yeah, trying to carry all the donuts!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It's like Shiori kept on helping me carry trees.
It's so hard.
Up the stairs.
Yeah.
So you know.
But whichever you know is good for you.
Yeah.
We hope that you enjoy it!
We're about to ponder.
It's time for a little bit of pondering.
Open!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
There's still gonna be one FUWAMOCO Morning before hibernation, so we hope that you'll share your walks, your doggy of a day, your Pero Sightings, too, and any other questions you might have with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Next stream is...
Goodbye Akiba MisDo Studio!
It's gonna be a little bit later than usual at midnight PT, so technically Thursday.
But there's a reason for that, okay?
We wanna be able to spend the very last hour that Akiba MisDo's gonna be open.
Together with you, Ruffians, you know.
Our last time going!
You know, we're really happy to be able to share a very special place together with you, Ruffians.
But you know, this time, we can say goodbye to Akiba MisDo all together like this, so we're really looking forward to it, Ruffians.
We hope you'll be there with us!
BAU BAU!
And let's take another look at our schedule here.
Well, on Thursday, we're gonna be helping out the investigation at Justice's Market Investigation in VRChat!
It's gonna be our first time playing VRChat and it looks like a lot of fun.
It looks like it'll be really cute and not scary.
Right?
Not scary, right?
Not scary, yeah?
So, we hope that you'll join us in Justice's first Halloween.
It's not a cup, we're helping!
Who cares?
Justice's first Halloween.
Those are the babies.
They don't know what Halloween is, huh?
We gotta show them what Halloween is, yeah.
Is that what we're doing?
I don't think so.
We'll see ya!
We're investigating.
But then after that, at 10pm PT, we're also gonna be doing a little bit of silly 3D trick or treating together with you Ruffians.
We just wanted to spend a little bit of Halloween together with you.
So we hope that maybe you'll share some of your candy with us and that we don't need to play any tricks.
Right.
Yeah.
No tricks.
Right.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And on Friday we have our last FUWAMOCO Morning before Hibernation with the last FUWAMOCO Morning this year.
So we hope that you'll spend it together with us.
But on the weekend, starting on Friday evening, we're gonna be getting into some monkey business.
Donkey Kong Country 2!
It's always a crazy time.
And then Saturday, a little bit more relaxed as we try to learn the ropes of Minecraft.
Again.
Just the two of us and you, Ruffians.
So please, really, please help us out because we really don't understand.
What is common sense in Minecraft is not common sense to us.
You put the stuff in the shape and it becomes the stuff.
That doesn't make sense.
How is that common sense?
Hi.
It's Moc.
Please help us.
BAU BAU!
And FUWAMOCO is joining us in the archive today!
Your FUWAMOCODEword is... BAU BAU!
We said it!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
That's a jump scare!
Jump scare.
Baby spooky.
Halloween.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, I'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
We'll be at YTM!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU BAU!